vielen dank tina tauß und herzlich
willkommen auf der plenarsaal ebene des
deutschen bundestags ja in der tat wir
können das was wir nachher ab 9 uhr im
plenum erleben auch noch mal kurz
verbinden mit dem was wir gestern schon
erlebt haben im plenum in der
generaldebatte als das thema
energieversorgung energiesicherheit und
energiekosten ja auch schon ein großes
thema gewesen ist im rededuell unter
anderem zwischen oppositionsführer märz
und regierungschefs scholz da ging es ja
auch schon ziemlich munter zur sache und
wir werden dieses ganze hier genauso
munter noch ein klein wenig vertiefen
und deswegen freue ich mich dass heute
morgen bei uns sind julia für linden
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen und die
anspannung ist bei uns stellvertretender
vorsitzender der cdu/csu-fraktion hier
im deutschen bundestag guten morgen frau
verlinken zwei allgemeinere
einstiegsfrage was ist eigentlich so
dramatisch daran oder was wäre so
dramatisch daran zu sagen wenn wir auf
die energieversorgung gucken und wie wir
die in dieser schwierigen lage
bewältigen wir lassen die atomkraftwerke
einen begrenzten zeitraum noch einmal
weiterlaufen bleiben aber atomausstieg
die debatte wäre abgeräumt sie hätten in
der koalition wahrscheinlich deutlich
weniger stress und es gäbe eine sage
nochmal eine klare perspektive für sagt
man maximal zwei jahre die atomkraft ist
eine hochrisikotechnologie und deswegen
haben unter anderem auch die entspannen
und alle anderen damals 2011 den
ausstieg erneut beschlossen und das ist
auch richtig so wir müssen raus aus
dieser gefährlichen energie erzeugung
und es macht einen unterschied ob wir im
augenblick alles daran setzen dafür zu
sorgen dass die netze stabil bleiben und
dafür leistet ihm die atomkraft kaum ein
beitrag das heißt was wir im augenblick
tun müssen ist und genau anzuschauen was
getan werden muss um eben auch die
lasten zu verteilen und vor allem muss
man auch noch mal dazu sagen was diesen
stresstest angeht nur unter ganz
bestimmten
schlimmen annahmen werden wir überhaupt
nur in einer krisensituation kommen also
die versorgungssicherheit ist
gewährleistet in deutschland und es ist
nicht damit zu rechnen dass wir ein
strommangel wir müssen also insofern ist
es ein guter weg zu sagen wir tun alles
um
da sicher jetzt auch durch den winter zu
kommen und die atomkraft ist einmal
keine sichere technologie wir gucken wir
uns ein zwei punkte gleich im anschluss
noch mal ran einen sehr wir haben ja
auch eine ähnliche einstiegsfrage was
wäre so dramatisch daran auch mal zu
sagen okay wir haben für den
atomausstieg gestimmt wir haben für den
kohle ausstieg gestimmt und wir haben in
den vergangenen jahren einfach viel zu
wenig für die erneuerbaren energien
gemacht höre ich nicht so häufig aus
ihren reihen nun zuerst der chef die
erneuerbaren energien haben sich
verzehnfacht in den letzten jahren ihren
anteil an der energieerzeugung ich
akzeptiere dass noch mehr passieren soll
aber es ist viel passiert aber wir sind
jetzt in einer anderen wir sind jetzt in
einer anderen lage wir haben krieg in
europa wir haben krisenlage und wir
haben ja jeden tag strommangel
höchstpreise an den strom und gasmärkten
entstehen weil mangel ist so ist der
markt in deutschland und in europa der
strombedarf ist riesig und in einer
solchen krise in einer solchen
ausnahmesituation muss man doch müssen
jedoch in der lage sein noch mal zu
schauen sind wir hier gerade auf dem
richtigen weg wir sollten alle formen
der energieerzeugung jede kilowattstunde
die geht nutzen dazu bei biogas dazu
gehören kohlekraftwerke
dazu gehören sichere die deutschen
kernkraftwerke sind nun wirklich sicher
und verlässlich sichere kernkraftwerke
und hier geht es darum die laufzeit für
die nächsten zwei drei winter zu
verlängern es geht nicht darum den
ausstieg ein ausstieg zu machen sondern
in der krisenlage stromproduktion für
deutschland zu sichern und das scheint
mir doch eine richtige wichtige
entscheidung die leider nicht getroffen
wird ganz kurz zurück zu meiner frage
alles richtig gemacht in den letzten
drei vier legislaturperioden das habe
ich nicht gesagt dass wir auch im
übrigen nicht ihre frage wir haben in
deutschland gemeinsam ist übrigens nicht
nur ein thema der union weil ich immer
die letzten 16 jahre höre was
aufzuarbeiten wie wir in diese große
abhängigkeit von russland von russischer
energie geraten konnten nord stream 1
wurde von rot-grün schröder/fischer
trittin entschieden wir sind diesen weg
ja auch weiter gegangen wir sind aus
kerne und kohle energie auf dem
ausstiegs weg und jeder wusste steht
übrigens auch im koalitionsvertrag der
ampel aus dezember noch drin das ist
dann die brücke hin zu den erneuerbaren
auch nach dem koalitionsvertrag der
ampel hätten wir mehr gaskraftwerke und
damit mehr russisches gas gebraucht also
ich akzeptiere unseren teil aber ich
habe schon den eindruck das war ein
breiter gesellschaftlicher konsens sie
haben eben dieser vorfall in die
energiesicherheit sei gewährleistet die
die netzsicherheit da gibt es überhaupt
keine probleme netzbetreiber haben dass
nach dem ergebnis des stresstest anders
gesagt die haben gesagt sie hätten
sicherheitshalber dann doch die
atomenergie noch dabei
ich muss da korrigieren ist ich habe
gesagt dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist
dass wir in einem krisenszenario kommen
wo die netzstabilität nicht
gewährleistet ist es hängt von ganz
vielen verschiedenen dingen das weiß man
ja vorher mit das ist ja das ist richtig
und genau deswegen ist ja auch der
vorschlag von robert habeck dass wir die
drei im augenblick noch am netz
befindlichen atomkraftwerke in eine
notfallreserve schieben dass wir sie wie
geplant am 31 12 abschalten wie es der
atomausstieg vorsieht und dann für den
fall der fälle das paar dass diese
unwahrscheinliche lage eintritt dass sie
doch noch gebraucht werden sollten
dann können wir sie wieder ans netz
nehmen das ist der vorschlag der grat
auf dem tisch liegt wir reden über sechs
prozent anteil am strommix glaube ich
maximal warum muss es unbedingt
atomstrom sein herr sparen warum nicht
alternative energien erneuerbare
energien weiter ausbauen wir stehen vor
einem winter vor einem wahrscheinlich
sehr harten winter für das wissen sie
auch nicht doch das ist ja schon
wettertechnisch meine wette naja es
winter ist jedenfalls kälter als sommer
dass sie glaube ich können wir immer
noch festhalten und deswegen werden wir
strom und gas mehr brauchen noch als im
sommer wir haben jetzt schon
höchstpreise ich habe auch diesen
stresstest nicht verstehen wir haben
jeden tag stresstest familien handwerker
pflegeheime wissen nicht mehr wie sie
ihre stromrechnung bezahlen sollen und
deswegen sind sechs prozent der
stromerzeugung kein game changer die
ändern nicht alles aber ein wichtiger
beitrag wie kohlekraftwerke wie biogas
der wirtschaftsminister sagt jeden tag
jede kilowattstunde zählt damit
begründet der dusch tipps
einsparverordnung wenn aber jede
kilowattstunde zählt zählt auch jede aus
dem kernkraftwerk an den preisen würde
es nichts ändern haben sich doppel gehen
darf doch doch das ist eine dieser mehr
dieser dieser geschichten die grad
erzählt werden natürlich würde etwas
ändern weil umso mehr deswegen wird ja
auch zum beispiel die kohle zurück ans
netz geholt um so mehr andere
energieformen wir ans netz holen desto
öfter entsteht der strompreis wird ja
jede stunde gemacht und so ist öfter
entsteht eine situation eine
preisbildung wo gas keine rolle spielt
klar es wird auch stunden geben vier
stunden geben wo der gas das
gaskraftwerk den preis immer noch
bestimmt aber umso mehr energie wir
vorher mit anderen auch mit erneuerbaren
aber auch kernkraftwerken erzeugen desto
weniger oft und damit wird der
durchschnittspreis sinken das ist so an
den märkten da haben sie mit dem kopf
geschüttelt ja genau weil wir haben
jetzt gerade am wochenende hat der
koalitionsausschuss getagt und
zahlreiche maßnahmen verabredet um die
preise auch auf dem strommarkt zu
stabilisieren beziehungsweise zu senken
so weit es geht dazu werden gerade auch
europäische gespräche geführt weil das
wichtig ist wir haben den europäischen
strommarkt und da macht es keinen sinn
wenn deutschland alleingänge macht
zumindest sollten deswegen sollten wir
es versuchen gemeinsam zu lösen und wir
haben zahlreiche maßnahmen auch
verabredet in der ampel umzusetzen um
auch menschen zu entlasten bei den hohen
energiekosten und ich finde wichtig an
der stelle noch mal darauf hinzuweisen
was wir da alles tun was wir
insbesondere auch tun um mehr
erneuerbare energien an den markt zu
bringen und da gibt es natürlich jetzt
sehr viel aufzuholen von den letzten
jahren wo der ausbau leider nicht so gut
voran gegangen ist und das müssen wir
jetzt alles mit hochdruck quasi
korrigieren von der vorgängerregierung
und da sind wir dran und wir haben
zusätzlich auch finde ich noch den über
sie haben das thema energiesparen
angesprochen eine option die wirklich
sehr viel bringt und vor allem auch bei
den preisen einen großen unterschied
macht ist es für mich
wirklich noch mal wichtig zu betonen
dass wir sehr sehr viel geld im
augenblick aufwenden um menschen dabei
zu unterstützen häuser energetisch zu
sanieren denn das ist doch die ursache
des problems das ist noch die ursache
ist aber das passiert ja schon seit
monaten wird die nachfrage oder
zuschauer die nachfrage nach
energetischer gebäudesanierung die macht
aber ein riesenunterschied und deswegen
ist es auch gut dass wir das problem an
der wurzel packen denn genau das hat uns
ja in dieser nicht nur die abhängigkeit
von russischen energie importen hat uns
eine schwierige lage gebracht sondern
auch dass die gebäude seit jahren
jahrzehnten mehr energie verbrauchen als
nötig und das heißt insbesondere die
alten ineffizienten
gebäude sorgen dafür dass menschen hohe
heizkosten haben und da sind hoch große
potenzial und da müssen jetzt an
wie viel um wie viel günstiger wird
meine kilowattstunde strom wenn diese
atomkraftwerke tatsächlich weiterlaufen
würden in dem umfang wie sie es sich
vorstellen das kann man so natürlich
auch ins endpreis nicht sagen aber eines
ist ihm klar dass marktwirtschaft umso
größer das angebot desto geringer der
preis und sie haben ja zu recht gesagt
stimmt absolut und aus überzeugung zu
keine alleingänge europäisch abgestimmt
alle alle unsere europäischen
nachbarländer bitten uns die
kernkraftwerke am netz zu lassen falls
er nicht nur um die deutsche nationale
netzstabilität geht sondern auch um die
europäische
alle sagen 'bitte produziert so viel
strom wie es geht wir brauchen ihn in
europa und deutschland geht da einen
unsolidarischen alleingang bei diesem
thema haben ja doch mal punkt preis
bestimmt werden ja weiterhin die
gaskraftwerke oder also auch selbst auch
wenn auch wenn die atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen wird ja über die
gaskraftwerke der preis bestimmt für den
strom das ist nein und das ist für ihn
dass seine mehr aber nur dann wenn die
gaskraftwerke benötigt werden wir haben
ja nicht den ganzen tag zu jeder
viertelstunde denselben strombedarf in
deutschland sondern der steigt und sinkt
der ist mittags höher als mitternacht
und umso öfter momente entstehen wo die
gaskraftwerke nicht gebraucht werden
weil die anderen so viel produzieren
wird eben auch dann nicht der strom da
gesetzt zumal die gas kraftwerke die
wärme kopplung machen die gebraucht
werden also für die wärme auch gar nicht
so mit in den preis mit einberechnet
werden also ist nicht ganz so einfach
auch beim strompreis wir uns das gerade
gelegentlich erzählt wird
möglicherweise sind es ein paar ganz
wenige minuten im monat liegt die frage
ist ja immer die atomkraftwerke
produzieren grundsatz strom und die
gaskraftwerke werden flexibel eingesetzt
insofern ist es einfach auch schwer
vergleichbar wie laufen
trotzdem ist nein tun die gaastra vettel
auch nicht durch viele würden selber
gesagt im moment im moment wissen
gaskraftwerke so viel gas verstromen wie
nie zuvor selten zuvor das ist doch in
der krise für strom wichtig wer nur
einfach darauf hinweisen sie haben halt
eine andere perspektive darauf ob wir
eine hochrisikotechnologie einsetzen
oder ob wir alle anderen optionen die
uns zur verfügung stehen mehr
erneuerbare energien auch aus dem jetzt
schon stehenden anlagen rausholen das
tun wir wir haben jetzt ein energie
sicherheitsgesetz eine reform
nein das ist jetzt dass das ist das weiß
nicht 20 30 gesetz was im energiebereich
jetzt beschließen werden in den nächsten
wochen also wir haben zahlreiche
rahmenbedingungen verbessert um mehr
erneuerbare energien ans netz zu kriegen
und auch aus den laufenden anlagen mehr
rauszuholen biomasse haben sie
angesprochen auch das ist auf den weg
gebracht und es geht darum dass wir
zusätzlich energie effizienz potenziale
nutzen und all das sind dinge die wir
tun und die auch erfolgreich einen
beitrag leisten und in der summe
ausreichen werden um die situation im
winter zu gewährleisten und falls der
unwahrscheinliche fall eintritt dass
doch nicht dann ist der vorschlag der
reserve auf dem tisch was ist er
modellen strompreise dauerhaft zu
stabilisieren oder sogar zu senken erst
mal so viel angebot wie möglich also
alles ans netz was geht zum zweiten die
rücklagen der region des eeg kontos zu
nutzen um netzentgelte und stromsteuer
fürs nächste jahr zu senken oder ganz
aufzuheben und zum dritten verlässlich
ein strom ein kran gas grundbedarf für
jeden haushalt der iss geplant aber
keiner weiß im moment wann der startet
zu welchem preis keiner kann plan für
den winter und das ist ein problem
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
hat ist dann diverse vorschläge gemacht
welche halten sie für realistisch was
die umsetzung angeht innerhalb der
nächsten zeit
deckelung gaspreis deckel für russische
gas importe reduziert von
im stromverbrauch in zeiten hoher
nachfrage
also das lastmanagement ist ein ganz
wichtiger teil und da dass das passiert
ja auch schon auf dem markt also
insofern ist das auf jeden fall etwas
was wir auch verstärkt einsetzen werden
aber zusätzlich finde ich eben auch
wichtig dass es gut ist dass europa sich
gemeinsam auch verabredet hat deutlich
dass auch einzusparen julia verdienten
vielen dank auch ihren sparen vielen
dank dass sie hier gewesen sein ich bin
ein bisschen irritiert wie sie gemerkt
haben weil ich irgendwie drin schon
applaus gehört habe die uhren hier die
in der lobby zeiten noch eine minute vor
neun ich würde sagen sie verlassen mich
ganz fix damit sie im plenarsaal sind
irgendwie also wir haben versucht da ist
ja immer noch vorn und klingelt auch
jetzt erst im hintergrund also etwas
ungewöhnliche situation vielen dank
bis zum nächsten mal und wir schauen
direkt in den plenarsaal rein meine
damen und herren